Ubisoft's video game movies aren't  stopping with Assassin's Creed I'm Tony  and this is your live action game spot  news update Ghost Recon wildlands is  getting a 30 minute short it's written  by Roberto or Chi whose credits include  Star Trek and the amazing spider-man 2  and it focuses on the game's villains  the Santa Blanca cartel the live-action  movie will premiere on twitch on  februari 16th just three weeks before  the game launches on March seventh it'll  be available on Amazon Prime immediately  after Ubisoft's first live-action outing  was Assassin's Creed in december of last  year it's currently sitting out of 36 on  metacritic and seeing as one of those  reviews came from yours truly I do hope  this wild lands short fair is better  keep an eye on gamespot for more when it  releases and for all the latest on ghost  recon you're already in the right place  you